JAN KLEINERT: Key
Visualizer for Cloud Spanner
is a tool in the
Cloud Console that
helps developers and operations
teams analyze Spanner usage
patterns.
It generates visual
reports for your databases,
broken down by ranges
of rows over time,
and it provides insights
into usage patterns at scale
that are difficult to
understand otherwise.
I'm going to walk
you through how
to use Key Visualizer to look
at usage patterns for a Spanner
database that's used by an
application I'm working on.
I've recently inherited
the responsibility
for this application, and I'm
not very familiar with it yet.
First, let's get acquainted with
the Key Visualizer interface.
When you access Key
Visualizer, you'll see a scan.
The core of a Key Visualizer
scan is the heatmap.
The heatmap shows us the
value of a metric over time,
broken down into
ranges of row keys.
The x-axis represents
time, and the y-axis
represents row ranges.
Low values are cold, represented
by darker colors like purple,
and high values are
hot, represented
by yellow or bright white
for the highest values.
The different patterns
in the heatmap
can help diagnose
issues at a glance.
Each row range represents
a contiguous set
of rows in a single
table or index.
A row range is defined
by a start and end key.
Within each table
or index, keys are
sorted by primary key values.
At the top of the
heatmap, there's
a key for the heatmap colors.
As you hover over a
cell in the heatmap,
you'll see details about
the value, timestamp, table,
and key bucket.
You can select a portion
of the heatmap to zoom in.
You can also select a time
range using the date picker.
You can pan around the heatmap
by clicking and dragging.
You can use the select box
to change between metrics.
When I look at the graph
for number of rows read,
I can see that the reads
for keys in the Albums table
are distributed fairly
evenly across row ranges.
However, for the
Singers table, it's
yellow or hot across the
board, and especially
in the beginning row ranges.
After looking at my
application code,
I notice the
query-singers-last name
function is called frequently.
I can see that we'd
probably benefit
from having a secondary
index on the LastName field,
so that Spanner
doesn't have to scan
the entire table every time
query-singers-last name is
called.
We can do this with a
CREATE INDEX statement
or by using force index.
I'll make the change
and see what happens.
With the application
change deployed,
we can see that the
number of rows read
has dropped dramatically
for the Singers table.
Seeing a single hot table
is just one common pattern
you may uncover
with Key Visualizer.
Here are some of the other
patterns you may encounter
and what issues
they might indicate.
A heatmap with a
single bright diagonal
line or a triangle
with a flat top
can indicate a database
that uses sequential keys.
Sequential keys are an
antipattern in Spanner,
and you can learn more about
why sequential keys cause
hotspots and alternatives in the
documentation on schema design
best practices.
A heatmap with horizontal
bands of bright color separated
by dark colors indicate
that specific row ranges
are consistently being more
heavily accessed over time.
To address this,
you can consider
changing your schema
design or your application
so that the data in
a heavily used row
or in an excessively large row
is spread across multiple rows.
A heatmap with multiple
diagonal bright lines,
either rising or
falling, usually
indicates sequential
reads or writes
to rows in a short
period of time.
If the lines correspond with
read activity, such as a table
export, no action
is usually required.
If you're experiencing
performance issues
during these reads,
you can consider
increasing the number
of nodes for instance
during those time periods.
If the lines correspond
with write activity
and you're experiencing
performance issues,
you should consider changing
your workload to a random write
instead of a sequential write.
A heatmap showing
bright horizontal bands
that appear partway
across the heatmap
indicate a sudden change in the
usage pattern of a database.
This could be a rogue query
or an unexpected surge
in activity for certain rows.
You can learn even more
about exploring heatmaps
and understanding heatmap
patterns in the Spanner Key
Visualizer documentation.
In this video, we've looked at
how Key Visualizer for Spanner
can help you analyze usage
patterns in your Spanner
databases.
This tool adds to
existing monitoring tools,
such as query stats and
monitoring in the Cloud
Console, to help simplify
the process of monitoring
and troubleshooting
performance issues.
In the description
below the video,
you'll find links to the Key
Visualizer documentation.
Key Visualizer is now available
for all Spanner databases,
so start exploring.